[Applause]
thank you
all right nice to be here um i'm
basically i'm an easily frustrated
individual like recently i went to go
buy some t-shirts right all i wanted was
like one solid color you know it took me
20 minutes just to find a t-shirt that
was just like one solid color you know
because nowadays all the t-shirts they
have like those like those stupid like
balls to the wall sports slogans across
them
you know what i mean they say like like
above the rim or like life short play
high there's like some 60 pound dork
standing there wearing the shirt going
yeah
yeah i'm crazy i got no fear
i think you should have the real slogans
across these t-shirts like no girlfriend
living at home with parents
83 escort yeah
living large making 14 an hour who's the
man
they're losers
these are the same people they go out
and they buy like those air jordans and
the shack shoe thinking it's gonna make
him like a better hoop player you know
something like 150 bucks he got the
shack shoe i'm going to be awesome
kicking the ball
like no dude you suck and now you're
poor
all right
so uh anyways um went out with this girl
the other night i got fixed up because
i'm a dork and that's basically how it
works and uh
i don't even know this woman okay don't
even know her and right off the bat she
starts like telling me all these crazy
stories about her life you know she
keeps making this face at the end of it
right she's like freaking me out she's
like oh my god bill you wouldn't believe
this right
this night i came in late i didn't think
it was any big deal but my mom is still
up she's like where have you been
i would say
have you seen girls do that i was like
the hell was that in me
she was like ending every story this way
the whole day she's like god blake today
cheer what's that afternoon boyfriend i
was like
it's like freaking out am i gonna have
to do end my stories with faces
okay i was driving to work today someone
cut me off i was like
[Applause]
it's ridiculous the whole day she's like
i'm going
everybody's looking at us like
fine just like brought it home like an
hour earlier and our dad was like
way to go son
so anyways i'm driving home
from the state and i'm alone right i'm
looking around my car okay i'm basically
you know i'm looking around i'm looking
i got four doors i got four seats i got
all this space you know you know what i
realized i don't need it
you know what i mean i live alone i
don't need a four-door car i need like i
got one passenger like one door one
little wiper a little one little spray
thing
you know just make the rest of trunk you
know what i mean
we know what stinks when you only need
one is everything comes in fours
you know the other day i want to buy
some dishes what do i get how am i gonna
get i get four plates
get four forks four spoons four knives
four glasses by a table i get four
chairs
you know all it is is a constant
reminder that i'm alone and i'm a loser
you know it's like wow look at all the
chairs
[ __ ] they're all empty oh yeah
tell you know what the worst are
our uh are the cookbooks
cookbooks are the worst cause it's
always cooking for four
you know i mean it's always like you
know you know and i i can't i flunk math
so i can't divide a third of a cup by
four so i gotta cut the whole stupid
thing
and all this spaghetti look at all the
spaghetti
why is there so much food oh yeah i'm
alive
i'm a loser they should have like a
loser cookbook
cooking for one alone and dealing with
it
recipes be like take three peas and one
carrot put it in the microwave and cry
[Applause]
so as you can see basically a frustrated
guy you know i've actually tried to look
back in my life see what the source of
all my anger is you know can't afford
therapy so i was like all right the hell
with it i'll analyze myself it's cheaper
what the hell
so i've actually i've narrowed this down
basically when i was a kid i still have
like bright orange hair it wasn't like
this reddish brown crap that you see it
was like it's like bright orange right
and it was like the 70s so i had this
big aphra
so i'm walking around like a total loser
but i'm three years old i just got here
i don't know i'm a loser right i think
i'm looking cool all right
so one day i put on the brady bunch
remember that episode where bobby washed
greg's hair
with that really cheesy shampoo
his hair like turns all orange he like
freaks out like looks right at the
camera he's like graduation's tomorrow
and i have orange hair
i'm like three years old what the hell
is wrong with that
my name's julie burr you guys a lot of
fun
very funny billy burr everybody